[Music]
hey what's up Samuel leaves here and
today this is thoughtful Thursday we're
gonna be discussing mortgages and if
you're too young to buy a property if
you're too young to get a mortgage if
you can't get a mortgage it off whatever
reasons or if you just want to know the
ins and outs of that how to finance a
property no better person to speak to
then a qualified independent mortgage
broker which is why I've caught on my
good friend out of the show Joe Joe Lane
great to have you on the show it's a
really good to talk with you you're from
Swansea Newport and that's for Swansea
but investing sands they the great thing
about you Joe the reason I like you so
much is number one is you're an investor
yourself yeah I know you've got a
double-digit property portfolio which is
great number two you're an expert
mortgage broker number three you're
really young yeah so you're how old are
you 23 23 so it's just great to have
that you know some because when I
started out in property I was super
young so why don't you start Joe just by
telling us anyone who's watching this
and doesn't really understand property
finance it's tell us a little bit about
what you do and why it's a good idea to
have mortgages instead of trying to just
buy properties for cash okay so I am a
specialist finance broker and I
specialize in property investors so the
reason why people should be using
mortgages to leverage it leverage their
funds to basically enable them to buy
more is because when you're borrowing
with a bank or any type of lender you're
paying a certain amount to lend that
money so you're paying on the interest
but if you're making rental income and
you're still making a net profit once
that mortgage has been paid that will
enable you to then use other funds to
buy more property and get a return on
that investment as well yeah absolutely
you know I've met some people I met one
lady she said to me Sam I'm flat broke
I've got no money there's no way I'd get
into property I'm struggling to put food
on the table for my kids all this stuff
and it turns out she had a property that
had been left to her as an inheritance
that she hadn't touched it was sat there
empty with no mortgage and the property
was worth three hundred thousand and
slight you think you're broke but you're
really not and then your job that you're
doing and you're only 15
to pound a month working your ass off if
you just sell that property or refinance
that property yeah you could go and buy
buh-buh-buh-buh pump a little portfolio
they could Mabel you two never have to
work again exactly so it's it's it's
almost knowing what to how to set up
your finances properly yeah and it can
make a massive difference
so I mean have you come across that sort
of stuff I get that a lot and I mean and
the main thing is is to straightaway
look at the asset because if the asset
could do with the reefer bananas
potential to grow the value of that
asset easy on the cost of what it would
take then is potential to for example
take out some short term finance to give
you some money to then refit that
property and increase the value further
to they'll enable you to put it on the
market and then sell it at a higher
price and you would have straight away
you know if you look into sell yeah
otherwise then to refinance it a better
sort of loan based on that loan to value
so here are the common ask questions
that I get all the time and I can't even
answer them because I'm not a mortgage
expert
at all so crash number one is it
possible to buy a property investment
without owning your own home yes okay
we'll go into that in a minute
number two is it possible to buy a multi
layer or a HMO with owning currently no
property investments yes Wow okay third
question is is it possible to refinance
your house and use all of that equity to
invest in other property investments
ninety percent of the equity and yeah
that's a 90 percent Oh horse I need to
leave something there not just a little
bit yeah of course but you can if you
could actually do property you can pull
a large percentage of that yeah money
out and reinvest it in proper said yeah
okay let's tackle those then let's let's
talk to them about those so first the
first one then on just can I start in
property I don't have any properties at
the moment I don't own my own property
I'm living with my parents or I am
living in a rented accommodation and I
want to get financed to invest in
property how does that work so basically
when you go for a residential mortgage
not talking about buy to let mortgage
lenders will generally lend you four and
a half times your gross annual income
obviously - any
the loans or credit cards might be
factored into that affordability now if
you don't have your own home and you're
looking to buy - lat
then bottle at lenders will treat you in
the same in the same way in terms of
maximum borrowing so if you are in a
situation via your income annual credit
cards and loans so this so that you
could maybe borrow two hundred thousand
on a residential basis well that would
be a maximum borrowing potential they're
not about to let mmm okay that's cool
but not on a bridge you know yeah if
you're looking at bridging affordability
isn't calculated in the same way yeah so
if you can for anyone that's not sure
what's the difference between a normal
mortgage and the bridging 400g loan well
a normal mortgage is a long term type of
loan and a bridging only short in
finance generally no more than 12 months
7 bridging products it's 10 to 18 but
it's definitely a short-term finance
facility and should not be used for a
long period of time
bridging is great when you're in a net
quickly because it enables you to to
many great things in property does it
help having a residential property if
you're wanting to invest or is that is
there no advantage that's all and there
are definitely more doors open to you
like you asked me earlier if you could
buy a hate you know we don't have in
your own property okay and if you have
your own home you could do that in your
own but if you don't have your own home
you'd sort of need to either JV with
someone to buy that on a mortgage or
you'd need to create HTML and then
refinance it so you're no longer a
first-time buyer when you do come to
refinance that hmm okay really and the
great thing is about mortgage brokers
yeah and particularly good ones like
yourself is a mortgage broker is someone
that basically just goes to all the
different lenders it has an individual
or an investment in front of them and
they creatively think how can I get this
person this financed and make you happen
basically yeah I mean there's just so
much so much criteria to know about I
mean the high street banks I mean you
might have B M solutions and CMW that
are linked to the high street banks and
people use them quite often but some
people don't know that a lot of the high
street banks that lend on HMOs they
require the whole heads to be into one
tenancy agreement and things like this
but if you know about specialist lenders
that don't have that requirement you've
just got more doors open to you and
potentially higher cash flow and yeah
more options in general okay so talk to
me about HMOs if
there's a lot of people that are told
and I'm sure it makes it a lot easier
but you say it's not essential that
before you can buy HMO that you need to
own a bike to let first you don't that's
the case no so let's say you've just
come to me now you don't own any
property but you've got money to put
down on a deposit and you've got enough
money to refill the property you're
looking at a property now it's a
three-bedroom house it's in a
non-article floor area so you don't need
planning permission to turn that
property into a hitch em oh yeah you buy
that property and on a bridging loan
yeah okay you turn it into a hitch ml5
bed you get it to rags and you get a
HTML license on the property start right
now at the rooms simultaneously to
finding your tenants you then go to a
lender searches Kemper Alliance that
doesn't require you to have any
experience in parts of that to lend to
you on HMO now as long as there's normal
Nate bedrooms that is within their
criteria and you could refinance up to
75% belong to value before six months
time so no six month rule can reliance
know Caroline's do go up to 85 percent
so if you did want to you know maximize
your borrowing potential and pull all
that cash back out and reinvest it
that's great and you can do so but that
would be after six months with camera
liens so if for instance you've done a
refurb your two months in on the
bridging loan you've refinanced it on
line three
you could go on Kemper Alliance is 75%
discounted variable mortgage which
doesn't have any Redemption penalties
which means that when it has been six
months
flip over to a five year fixed and then
further advance up to 85 percent loan to
value in tupelo you cash a very very
good very good
so if you are buying would you like to
buy a property like say a four-bed Multi
left without having to get a bridging
loan and then we follow that singer
if you JV with someone who was a
homeowner then yes if you if you if not
then oh okay cool so basically it's just
about being creative and thinking what
would the saying no it's like saying
well how can I like that yeah because
the yeah you you can you can pull all
together you can find someone who's got
the either the experience or is a
homeowner themselves oh yeah oh I know
you know bit about more story and I've
explained to you how I bought my first
house when I was 17
and I did it with the help
of putting it in a family members name
yeah say for a 15 16 year old that was
really excited about property prepared
to learn prepared to work hard and they
just physically are way too young to
actually buy a property what advice
would you give to them well I think the
same thing goes for for example someone
who might be looking to set up a company
for their children maybe you've got two
parents they look and set the limited
company and their children like one or
two mm-hmm it'd be the same way is if
you had someone who's 15 and they wanted
to invest at that point because what you
could do is open a limited company
whether you're 15 or 1 you could have a
hundred percent shares in that company
but what actually really matters is
who's the director of that company so if
mum and dad wanted to go director they
would actually be the guarantor on the
mortgage and then the shareholders which
would be the child children in this case
wouldn't actually go on a mortgage
that's pretty cool so the lenders will
lend to write it on the parents yeah
yeah no but they could the directors at
some point resolved and then the kid
becomes the new director down the line
yes when they get to the age of 18 that
is that is impossible or depending on
the lender maybe 21 so I know precise
mortgages they will allow you to open a
limited company yeah for your children
so they're 100 percent shareholder
parents and directors they will
underwrite it on the appearance at the
precise mortgages have a minimum age of
21 for the mortgages yeah I'm a bridging
his 25 it's a bit lower happened to make
is when I was 17 I was thinking I might
do the 18th and stop buying properties
yeah because the normal conversations
that we have is how can you buy property
start with no money and of course
there's loads of ways you can borrow
everybody from someone you get there's
lots of different ways you can do it but
I knew that bit but my problem was I'm
too young to buy a house and I think I
can't write to the 18 so I can finally
be old enough to buy a house and then if
my broker said to me I'm really sorry
but to buy a body to that property you
got to be 21 and I'm thinking I got
white done 21 and that's why I had to be
really creative and I came up with a
similar concept till 2 what you've done
really really good advice ok cool if
someone wants to go ahead and get a
mortgage I'll be the first steps so I
always say speak to a broker so how
would that work for you low
so if they're looking to just get
standard mortgage bond property and run
it that's already done no refurbed quite
clear-cut then it would just be a case
of them coming to me once they've had an
offer accepted then we would need
standard documents like ID proof of
address then it would be income
documents and bank statements to
evidence the income yeah because all the
checks that the lenders will do once
we've got ideally verified the
individuals then we're in a position
where we can then apply for mortgage but
we would need to know what the purchase
price is going to be so yes so the
adjustment you said the first thing is
go and find a property yeah and I think
that a lot of people that gets tickets
so oh I don't know if I get a mortgage
like this the first thing I always say
is just figure out how to find good
property deals because if you go to a
broker there's no property mind you
don't know what strategy you want you
don't know what area you've just got no
idea yes it's harder to help them all
right cool so talk to me a little bit
about people who have got bad credit or
people that comment how could they
you've mentioned I'll just joint-venture
of somebody how would that work well I
mean bad credit could go it the same way
if it was really bad anyway we're
talking banquets you know they could go
the same way as when you're working with
foreign nationals swapsies you know
foreign nationals don't have access to
the UK finance products like contra
liens precise all of this sort of stuff
but they do if they're less than twenty
four percent shareholder and limited
company because if you're less than
twenty four percent shareholder
generally you don't need to go on the
mortgage application which means you
don't get into written so if you've got
bad credit
seriously and you're not on a mortgage
application then you're not in the
written in it's no longer a problem but
if you do have bad credit and you want
to be more involved in that
then there are certain lenders like Vita
home loans but have Tier one two three
and four products with their credit
score you and see which tier you fall
into an ATO one being the cheapest and C
have four being the more expensive visa
still have very specialist types of
criteria such as a three-month rule if
you refinance him from bridging rather
than a six and they will lend up to
eighty five percent loan to value which
is probably one of three in the market
yeah very very my word
roughly yeah let's just talk now not
HMOs or just general by to that property
buying a house to rent out what other
lenders saying what what you needed to
put down as a deposit these days fifteen
percent with a minimum fifteen percent
is low enough yeah that's very low see
when I teach at the crash courses and
stuff i teach 25 percent 25 percent yeah
fact that you can put that in just 50
percent so in other words you're saying
if you've got a house you're buying for
a hundred grand
you only need 15,000 pound deposit to be
able to buy that property
yeah with certain lenders I mean yeah
some lenders have have different
criteria like camera lines for example
that do it the minimum 100k on that type
of lens value you go to V there and I
would fit pretty impressed exactly yeah
so based on what I teach which is put
down 25% and then have 75% on the on the
mortgage and I think that's a little bit
more cuz you yeah I think it's great to
leave rid yourself on the average of
money but there's a point isn't there we
just say yeah where it can be a little
bit too stretch you don't live in the
situation whereby you really leveraged
and then and then suddenly prices dip a
little bit well it's it's not just that
I mean when you're highly geared some
lenders will not look at you so so tmw
for example when you bet to a certain
amount of bite alerts that are owned if
your portfolio's kids honey any higher
than seventy five percent loan to value
they will not look at you yeah when I
started out I would have happily had 100
percent more positive as well you know
billion percent because I'm starting out
I'm desperate to buy some houses I've
probably got nothing I wanted to get I
wanted to put down as little as possible
and leverage the bank's money as best I
possibly can hundred percent yet but I
think you know in your situation my
situation when you've got our portfolio
you've hit your financial goals then you
might not be so bothered about getting
as absolute much as possible
yeah how interest rates do at the moment
then so typical buy to that seventy five
Altuve yeah yeah so starting from two
point seven nine with the precise at 75
yeah which is low company that so a
limited company borrow in couple years
ago is obviously more expensive as you
probably
yeah but it's getting cheaper now
because it's becoming more common
yes banks are getting used to
underwriting at t MW of high street
lender of now connect with the limited
company products so they're getting used
to it the rates steady I don't think
anyone's really bothered about brexit
Magellan pulled out of the market not so
long ago that wasn't because a brexit
that was because they find it too
competitive in the market and they
couldn't reduce their rates to come Wow
interesting
so it is yeah what do you think about
one general formula because what I say
at the and I looked at every sort of six
months or so I'd love to just talk to a
broker about this and check that I'm I'm
not saying anything out of date but when
I'm fine when we're funded by two that
seeing all that properties I generally
say if you as a template now you can do
better than this then that's great but
as a general rule of thumb template if
you can work on the basis of put down
25% I have 75 percent as a mortgage and
then your interest payments interest
only is going to be around about 3% does
that seem reasonably we had a stick yeah
yeah yeah so if you're one of those
people that are really negative and
conservative and pessimistic and always
see the glass half empty
at the moment there could be some people
that could say I'm worried about
interest rates rising they're really low
at the moment so what would you
recommend those people to fix him for
five year fixed if their risk averse
yeah okay
and how much would that would you go to
if you're fixing them it does it make it
a lot more expensive or can you still do
it every one three four so yeah it's
still gonna be within that I mean
precise for example they're at three
point eight four four five year fixed
that's not bad can you fix it for ten
years yes because I think I think we
just fix one of our seniors just just
because we thought why not and I think
it was about 5%
yeah sure broke their tenure fixed yeah
and so if you're worried about it so
what you're telling me is if you worried
about interest rates going up mm-hm
you cut you can if you want fix the
interest rates for up to as long as 10
years yeah so it's okay okay interesting
so really if you fix them for 10 years
and you're still making a good profit in
cash flow yeah I mean the three and a
half percent seventy five percent
five-year fix that's pretty good design
yeah absolutely and when people talk to
me what happens if interest rates go up
what would turn into reports go up I
just think you know what
you think that I see going up at the
moment or read it yep I do
yeah so and and and and and the rents
would have to follow if the interest
rates went out it's the stuff part of
the economy isn't it yeah so you know I
think the economy could probably benefit
with the rates going up I personally
start my deals on five six percent
anyway so yeah if the interest rates
went up I would still be making profit
on my deals yeah exactly did you paint
to Japan a month on the interest yeah
and you're renting out the 700-pound
it its interests have got to go up and a
ridiculously long way before you even
break even if your worries about you
know 11% or whatever it would still it
would still work on my cash flow and
investments such as I say or hmm yeah
exactly I can really just fix you - yeah
so why do you think people do that
worried about things like this I think I
think it's just pessimism sort of but
it's not even essential as well I think
it's in a social asset because when when
some you know you've the old saying if
some things too good to be true
sometimes it is and that's what people I
think it just got stuck in their heads
he and so you go rangs and I personally
don't accept advice I only accept
counsel from people who what are the
fruits well counsel is advice from
people who are qualified in the subject
matter that you seek advice in yeah look
go an advice is not necessarily asking
anyone who's got any clue so advice
would be from your parent act like you
haven't done it exactly or from your
school teachers or Dave down the pub
would be advised but counsel is from
okay that's good so generally anyone who
is worried about interest rates shooting
up significantly I don't think is looked
into it enough yeah that's true
what are your thoughts on bricks it from
the economy point of view in the mark I
think by happens of breakfast it'll be
good go on explain I think you can make
a positive out of any scenario that
happens yeah I guess if prices go down
mm-hmm and they start rocketing down
which it could happen then great Mike
you could buy you can buy discount
properties because I didn't hold them
and wait for them to go up again because
they well yeah they were because my
portfolio is quite diverse in the sense
that got single at some HMOs if the
prices went down in the HMOs would cover
the mortgage payment you
and then I have an opportunity to then
buy more properties at a very low price
where are your hedgerows Swansea okay
well it is I mean the student markets
changed a bit professionals is what I do
yeah obviously Swansea is Pat Wales
Wales is article for the whole of Wales
yeah so you don't have the luxury of
article fort is hey sure it is yeah I
thought I don't need a license to be a
landlord I'm pretty sure that the whole
world is out court for looking to that I
think that is definitely and could you
let me know if it's not do you mind
give us a little bit of inside
information on your project at the
moment because I know it's massive and
exciting yet so there's one that we're
which right very hard for now and
there's 35 Apartments is by the boats
dude that's big boy stuff yeah it's
great - listed and we're hoping for ten
houses around as well just do the ten
salimah in Luke 23 yeah 23 working on
projects like that but no I mean stuff
like that I mean it's great but me
personally my goals for this year a
single that's so I've done the HMO stuff
great happy with that yeah but now I
want single that's boy because single
ads are never ever gonna be a gonna
quite a fashion everyone needs single as
families are growing we're in a housing
crisis so when I want to do single outs
there's no planning really and I'm
actually gonna try not lift the value
but generally it's so easy to borrow
that property with a little money down
do a library ferb refined out and say
get all your money back out I mean
you're not really really down on exactly
doesn't it really doesn't make a
difference but with it with the HMOs
because I'm from Wales and obviously
like I said about the planning issues
that I've been having there's just a lot
a lot more to consider and it takes a
lot longer so Jamie plumbing to turn any
single that house into a HMO even if
it's just a 3-4 bed HMOs you need
planning and why else yeah obviously you
will be writing about article 4
yeah because I don't know a lot of
people get confused about the difference
between article 4 and licensing I know
no no so okay yeah and you probably are
yes I mean good for an investor that
Savion knows what they're doing then you
haven't got the competition of anyone
trying to do it in the permit
development hmm
but yeah I mean it just makes that a bit
more difficult because you can't just
for example buy a property on a bridge
with the intention to tell the lender
that you can turn it into HMO because to
do that they're gonna want to see your
planning proof that it's actually gonna
you're gonna buy that property turn into
HMO in a timely manner yeah and then be
able to refinance a or sell what do you
think of because we're really interested
I know when section 24 was announced
that must have been in 2016
yeah and now there's news articles
talking about it as if is like just
happened or just been announced
something delicious oh I think it's
because people are feeling that bit more
[Applause]
pop you were talking about for years but
it's really interesting because section
24 was announced and then what happened
is as you know everybody suddenly
started buying through a company yeah
because when your wife through a company
section 24 doesn't apply right yeah
however buy for a company used to be a
nightmare but I always say this the
people that make the rules are usually
the same people that make money in
property you know so as long as you're
in the top 1% and you're educated and
you're aware and you have these sorts of
doors you can usually find the loophole
to get around the the new bad the bad
problem so you know so buying through
our company is now easier than ever and
from what you've said that sounds that
sounds like the case not even from a tax
perspective but from a maximum borrowing
perspective mortgage wise there is
actually more benefits buying a limited
company because if you're a high rate
taxpayer and you're buying a lunatic
company all lenders will stress you at a
hundred twenty five percent
rental coverage which in other words for
people who don't know means that if
you're a high rate taxpayer buying your
own name and you're getting stressed at
one hundred forty five percent you can
borrow less in your own name as you
could in a limit because it's crazy
isn't it and also I mean I used to buy
as an individual to tell about 2016 when
in section 24 was announced and then I'm
thinking and I was advised by my
accountant stop whinin limited companies
always start by a few companies
2016 what would what's the process in a
blind through a company because I know
that much easier now because effectively
you buy for a company you can set up a
commonly today buy for it tomorrow and
you can just act as a as a guarantor
point in the game does that work well
you know a lot of people come to me and
they say well I've got this business and
I'm thinking like buying a couple of
properties in there and I say well old
fire just a second I think people just
assume that that lenders prefer to lend
to a company that's two years old but in
fact that's not true
because when you've got a limited
company that has been trading it's hard
directors resigning
these skeletons in the closet you know
there's no risk to that lender to lend
you that that company yeah well they'd
much prefer it's a brand new company
with the standard industry codes to be
just for the letting the management of
property the sale of own property
there's about three I can send that out
you've probably got information on that
yeah sure but the it's messy isn't it it
is
it's just when you've got a company
that's been driving its massive weight
if you just I know this company was
actually just set up yesterday things up
okay
no questions to ask exactly and it's
harder a lot more long winded if you
come please be going if it has been
traded in there a couple of bites let
lenses to look at it like Lambay but
generally you can have to go to a
commercial lender which is more
expensive mini interest rate legals
everything really yeah so basically
you're better off open a brand new
company and then find property in it
tomorrow talk to me about mortgage hosts
I can't get a mortgage but I've got a
joint venture partner or a friend or
whoever
that's very happy to be more mortgage
host when we talk about host young for
you not to go on the limited on the
mortgage application you would have to
be less than 24 percent shareholder in
the limited company talk to me then
about buying a property this is what
everyone's excited about right now yeah
buying a promise day yeah reefer thing
yet yeah refinancing it pulling out as
looked possible money as you can ideally
all of it mhm
and then restore like to leave your cash
again and again how does that work and
can you help people with that on a
finance level yeah definitely so I'm I
mean buying a property that needs a
large refurb you don't actually need all
the refurb money there so say you found
the property that's worth two hundred
thousand and it needs
say a hundred thousand spendin on it
the relent out there that will lend you
68 percent of the purchase price net and
then 100 percent of the bill costs so
that means that how much was the bill
got 100 percent so okay talk me through
that so let's say that if you didn't
have this lender you'd need to fund two
hundred thousand of the purchase and
100,000 towards the build so you would
think if you were cash if you're all put
your own money who knew been three
hundred thousand cash straight until we
do for the house 100 for the okay and
what if you do it with smartphone apps
so just need thirty two percent deposit
if you've got experience acting capital
will do that at 32 percent that's how
you put it but you just said deposit
down on the property yeah but then
you'll be able to get a hundred percent
phone that's on the development works
yeah as long as the GDP is healthy which
it would need to be anywhere that you
wouldn't buy a course of course yeah and
then that should fit that's cool yeah
that's cool well Joe I don't really
enjoy picking your brains over this
interview and it's really good working
with you yeah thanks for sharing the
golden dawn of it and hopefully do it
again maybe a six twelve months and I'm
sure that we plenty of new stuff
designer Claire's always changing so
yeah
[Music]